you will see Charlize Theron's and Seth
Rogen as they team up in the romantic
comedy long shot and we have an
exclusive look behind the scenes I've
been a huge Seth Rogen fan great to hear
[Music]
really only wanted to make the movie
with her and it took us like seven years
to get successful enough to get Charlize
Theron in our movie yeah landing the
oscar-winning actress may have been a
long shot but Seth has always wanted to
make a rom-com like this what if we made
the kind of movie I grew up watching
that is actually romantic and actually
funny usually in movies where a lot of
people die this could be fun there's
something about Seth when he walks into
a room he's just incredibly confident at
what he brings to the table I was very
very impressed
Secretary of State looking at us I kind
of know her please remember Who I am
really nice to see you again
in the movie Charlize is Charlotte a
presidential candidate who used to
babysit sess character Fred now he's a
journalist hired to write her speeches
he has a thousand constituents how they
would feel if Kate Middleton say really
one of us were to start dating Danny
DeVito pretty negative reaction
this is Charlize his first leading role
in a romantic comedy but Seth said she
had no problem calling the shots on set
when they filmed a sexy scene I'm having
to bossy know that sparks fly
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]